[Music]
what is going on there reject nation
greg and john here today i'm looking
forward to doing this video very much so
so much so that i think we would all
agree that it would behoove you to leave
a like
if you can guys sam raimi with his
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness movie coming out he is now
talking about what he would want first
before agreeing to go forward with a
spider-man 4. yes years ago he wanted to
do spider-man 4 but ultimately left the
project and he said that it would be
these same demands that he would want to
make sure fulfilled before
agreeing to do it and i think he even
talked recently about how with the
multiverse being open it has definitely
opened up his own mind
being willing to go ahead and maybe give
it another shot i wanted to go through
these four specific questions that he
has will the story fulfill these four
questions so what i wanted to do to make
this a little more fun we'll go through
the four questions one at a time then
i'll kind of give
my little pitch of what i think would be
good for spider-man 4 because i don't
think he should be doing what he
originally had planned especially
because of the fact that it's been many
years and the fact that tony maguire was
just in spider-man no way home but you
know something akin to what uh he was
probably hoping for down the road are
you ready for this i'm so ready ready
for this and you guys can uh vote in the
comments which one did you like more now
it is a competition
all right guys so the first question
here is
does toby mcguire want to do it uh i'm
going to say no
absolutely not
that's an easy one does toby maguire
want to do it that's the first thing he
presents tom mcguire himself has already
stated the door is not closed and that
there's more stories that could be told
i think tomogram would of course be into
it if sam raimi specifically wanted to
return to direct it as well so now let's
go through the fun stuff two
is there an emotional arc for him i was
thinking what could the arc for him be
especially post no way home with toby's
version in no way home he's obviously
the older one and in a lot of ways they
play to that as him being a little bit
more of the wiser one amongst the three
of them and i feel like that would have
an effect on him when returning to his
own home world encountering the
situations with tom holland and zendaya
seeing what happened with andrew
garfield and they left the door a little
bit open and mysterious as to what
happened between him and mary jane on
his world i think the emotional arc for
him would be him contemplating whether
or not he should hang up the suit and
maybe there is an opportunity for
someone else to actually take up the
mantle for being the hero especially
after going to another world where other
heroes do exist and seeing someone like
andrew garfield who didn't get a chance
to be with his loved one that maybe he
should be giving this all up he's much
older now and maybe he should reevaluate
his situation here it's gonna be so many
years i don't know if you get another
trilogy out of this but there's also got
another chance to get old man spider-man
in this one so there's question three
and four and i'm gonna just put them
both in some one category here is there
a great conflict and is there a great
villain now for me i think that the
villain he said that he wanted to do
this but the one that sprang to mind for
me would be craven the hunter and the
reason why i think craven the hunter
would be a great fit is because he could
feed into his emotional conflict
specifically craven the hunter depending
on the interpretation but the one i grew
up on was one who was just a big fan of
the sport a big fan of hunting of the
most dangerous game what would feed more
into his conflict of if he should give
up the suit or not would be a man who
comes to new york city specifically
wreaking havoc in the city because he's
after spider-man a lot of the times
these villains have their own motives
they're doing their thing and then
spider-man interferes and it's like
spider-man is getting in the way of my
plans but what if the plan of a villain
showing up and causing chaos is
because of spider-man specifically which
would add more to is what i'm doing
actually right to bring
someone who's not even from new york all
the way to new york just to try to kill
me
you know and it's getting others harmed
in the way as well that's what i mean
you have a physical conflict and then
you have an internal conflict that he
has to deal with and the problem is
choice by the end of the movie you know
can he find someone else to be a hero
for the city because in his world
there's no other heroes that he knows of
can he train someone can you duplicate
the radioactive spider like what can you
do here would you introduce some miles
morales played by
finn wolfhard
that's the way to go
yes sir
or timothy chalamet
throw him in there white washroom that's
what we want
oh can you imagine what people would say
online does that sound that sounds so
good that i can only just add on top of
it because i'm not gonna have a better
idea than you so yeah that's my basic
idea that i think he could do like you
know obviously we need an outline in the
meat and bones and stuff but uh yeah
that's what sprang to mind when i read
those questions so that's a great take
on on what a spider-man 4 could be i
feel like you're onto something really
good but see here's the thing i thought
about you know we're getting a crave in
the hunter movie and sony probably not
gonna want to dilute the waters by
having two spider-centric craven movies
trying to establish one unless you cross
aaron taylor johnson over with toby
maguire but i feel like that might get a
little bit distracting some my version
it's multi-version i know but sony i
think really wants to get their side
multiverse that will not probably hinge
on toby maguire off the ground first as
much as i want to just be like hey
multiverse i gotta have a different
answer so where's the fun in that uh i
think that in the pursuit because yeah i
want to see toby's peter you know in
that more mature place also appreciating
the connections the bonds that he have
after witnessing what tom holland had to
give up what andrew garfield wasn't able
to hold on to that he toby maguire
spider-man is in that pursuit of finding
a replacement things go horribly awry
and give birth to the man spider and
then peter parker is forced to look at a
perverted version of himself an inverted
and traumatized version of himself but
within that there is a road to the way
forward and to reclamation because we
can have a sensitive monster movie which
sam raimi is also good at showing that
the man spider is just a victim of
circumstance and classic spider-man
theme science gone awry but not the same
kind of like oh a doctor mentor kind of
dynamic it would be something fresh and
that way you could really prioritize you
know their uh relationship with mary
jane his family what he wants to protect
but also having to write this last
scientific debacle before moving on to
eventually fighting craven in the better
movie that you wrote actually i think in
a lot of ways what you have is is better
i mean you incorporated the science
which is something that that movie lost
sight of that franchise is true
i mean there's scientists involved but
really peter's interest in science feels
the most plugged in in no way home you
incorporated a bit of more of that sam
raimi whimsy horror spider a man spider
woman sounds more like a dark
psychological spider
yeah
which i also want to see and then mine
would be like spider-man meets evil dead
the fly body horror
you [ __ ] an actual sam rave spider-man
movie and i pitched like a ex's stitch
which i guess spider-man 2 is this is a
great thing to vote on though because
both movies would be exciting because
one would force sam raimi to stretch his
legs to further places we're not as used
to seeing bring some of those english
patient vibes in i'm bringing it more to
like spider-man 2.
yeah yeah
and uh you know mine is a little bit
more like hey let's just let sam raimi
do his thing yeah so what do you want
you know well guys tell us down below by
the way great pitch energy thank you
he's really calm in mine i think we're
thinking of a great pitch energy to that
you know i've just been watching so many
ryan george videos
gotta get that energy
all right guys vote